philibert merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors ce texte
européen d'appel au don vise à lever 1,7
milliard 5 d'euros on le disait de dons
pour la recherche d'un vaccin contre le
coc vie de 19 alors qu'est ce que cela
révèle les caisses sont vides
les caisses sont vides pas du tout
puisqu'en fait l'union européenne a par
le biais de la banque centrale
européenne mimile milliards d'euros sur
la table créer mille milliards d'euros
d'argent public pour faire monter les
marchés financiers et sauver la finance
donc là les cas sont pas vides qu'il
budget de l'union européenne est très
très importante avec 7 milliard et demi
d'euros
ce n'est pas grand chose pour l'union
européenne donc mais moi ce que ça
révèle plutôt c'est qu'en fait on est
dans la société du spectacle parce que
c'est d'un téléthon mondial c'est comme
ça qu'il l'appelle c'est la société du
spectacle on fait du spectacle au lieu
de l'action et on en appelle aux
milliardaires aux multinationales pour
donner de l'argent va les mettre en
scène on va les mettre devant
au lieu de mettre devant lé dernier de
cordée qui ont travaillé et l'autre
chose qui est importante c'est que la
charité d'accord mais la charité
médiatisé que l'on montre on montre
qu'on donne c'est contraire aux
principes de la charité donc c'est une
action qui est un petit peu enfin je
trouve franchement gênante
on aurait préféré que plutôt que de
faire du spectacle l'union européenne
fasse de l'action et rentrer dans
l'action contre le coc vite 19 parce que
les donateurs visait finalement vous
nous le disiez ce sont les grandes
fortunes les grands chefs d'entreprise
les grandes fondations c'est bien cela
oui tout à fait et les gouvernements
d'autres pays donc qui sont visés or
nous on aurait voulu et tous les
citoyens je pense et tous les les
français les allemands auraient voulu
que l'union européenne ne fasse pas dû
chômer phase de l'action
or peut-être qu'elle veut faire oublier
ces actions qui sont assez pathétique
puisque l'union européenne est basée sur
la solidarité c'est un fondement nous le
rabâche à chaque élection européenne
pour nous vanter l'union européenne il
n'y a eu aucune solidarité
l'italie n'a pas été aidée elle a été
aidée par la chine la russie et cuba et
malheureusement pas du tout par l'union
européenne ils se sentent abandonnés les
masques ont été volés aussi entre les
différents pays l'allemagne a
réquisitionné tout son matériel médical
et a refusé qui est plus d'exportations
de matériel médical à tel point que
l'italie et les italiens sont tellement
déçu que 50 % maintenant veulent sortir
de l'union européenne ou de l'euro on
peut parler aussi de la pro
position d'ursula von der leyen qui a
fait une proposition pourquoi absolument
ignobles pour que les personnes âgées ne
sort pas de chez elle
il n'est pas de relation jusqu'à la fin
2021 pour que le business continue et je
vous promets que je ne mens pas à les
regarder sur internet pour tous les
internautes qui est il et aider les gens
qui regardent la télévision et qui n'y
croient pas
l'essai européen discovery aussi est
pathétique puisque cet essai qui a été
lancé il ya un mois et demi au nom de
l'union européenne est un fiasco selon
l'infectiologue qui mène cet essaim
lepage l'infectiologue français qui est
patron du consortium
on n'a pas de résultats au bout d'un
mois et demi où ça arrivera trop tard et
il n'y a même pas d'horizon lancé pour
avoir un résultat sur quels médicaments
marche
est-ce que l'hydroxyde chloroquine ça
marche ou pas est-ce que les autres
médicaments marche ou pas et jusqu'aux
la commissaire européenne vers sneijder
qui a expliqué qu'il fallait pas dette
d'états en fait il fallait faire il
fallait des aides d'état mais qu'elle
elle est vérifiée qu'il y en ait pas
trop alors même que tout le monde veut
sauver les entreprises des grandes
entreprises et les petites qui risquent
la faillite parce qu'il faut pas
détruire notre tissu économique c'est
fondamental et pas créer du chômage de
masse alors ce grand téléthon pour
trouver un vaccin ce grand appel aux
dons devraient en revanche se réaliser
sans les états unis
comment comprendre cette absence que je
pense que les etats unis eux ils ont
envie d'agir au niveau national parce
que c'est beaucoup plus efficace on a vu
que ça ne fonctionne pas ces actions
supranationale au dessus des nations en
fait l'union européenne envoie le
message aux à tous les européens
finalement elle est toujours dans la
mondialisation il faut plus de
mondialisation est un show mondiale
malheureusement sans les états unis et
tout cela au moment où on voudrait plus
de local plus de national des
relocalisations d'entreprises et c'est
vrai que c'est un vrai problème c'est le
programme de trump ce n'est pas lui qui
veut des emplois américains retrouver
son industrie ce n'est pas le programme
de l'union européenne qui a décidé qu'il
nous fallait plus de mondialisation
même si la mondialisation s'est avéré un
terrible piège pour la france avec le
manque de masse de respirateurs de test
et j'en passe alors pour conclure cette
plate forme de dons et sens et je cite
je
t les bases d'une véritable alliance
internationale pour lutter contre le coc
vide 19 est ce que cette initiative pour
bart rebattre les cartes en termes de
coopération internationale justement
selon moi je pense que la coopération
internationale c'est des choses qui sont
voulus entre les nations et pas à partir
d'organismes supranationaux comme
l'union européenne qui vivent de ça donc
je pense que de toute manière s'il ya un
vaccin qui est trouvée dans un pays les
autres personnes dans les autres pays
auront accès et plutôt que de faire une
initiative monstre un truc englobant et
mou il vaudrait mieux donner à plein de
chercheurs différents à une multiplicité
d'organismes et chaque pays est libre de
le faire
et à partir de cela que le meilleur
gagne que le meilleur trouve le vaccin
que le plus chanceux trouve le vaccin
est de toute manière il sera partagé
avec le monde entier j'ai pas une
seconde l'idée qu'un pays pourrait le
garder pour lui et ne pas le partager
avec le monde entier
merci beaucoup philippe muray re d'avoir
répondu à nos questions javel que vous
êtes économiste
merci